I'll play the video clip in just a
moment but it's fair to say that Elon
Musk is quickly becoming one of the most
famous people on planet Earth born in
South Africa and who is now a Canadian
American he has become a billionaire
business magnate CEO and co-founder of
several companies including the car
company Tesla Solar City the boring
company SpaceX and others however most
people are completely unaware of the
name Nikola Tesla and I'll discuss
details on that in just a moment
but Nikola Tesla is perhaps the most
prolific inventor of all time with
hundreds of patents around the world
including arguably 80% of the technology
that we use every single day can be
credited in some way to Nikola Tesla and
the Tesla car company is named after
Nikola Tesla as he's the one that
invented the AC induction motor which is
of course utilized in Tesla's cars but
what Elon Musk said about Nikola Tesla
when he was asked about him in an
interview well you may find it a bit
interesting so before I play that clip
there's a few details that you need to
know Nikola Tesla created the technology
to harness the AC or alternating current
which is used to connect and power the
electrical grid throughout the modern
world
we also use DC or direct current for
example that is what's used to power my
laptop as well as charging our cell
phones in shorts alternating current can
travel significantly further distances
than direct current and essentially
without it we would need power plants in
practically every city I mean imagine
that literally thousands of more coal or
nuclear power plants throughout the
world now we have all heard of Thomas
Edison an Edison hired Nikola Tesla to
improve the DC technology which is how
and when Tesla came to develop the
technology to harness the alternating
current which is far superior for
supplying electricity to a city what you
probably don't know is that Edison had
promised Nikola Tesla $50,000 which by
the way is equivalent to a couple
million dollars in today's value but he
refused to pay Tesla in an attempt to
save face and increase profits by
bolstering the use of the direct current
and he went on to start an aggressive
marketing campaign to discredit Nikola
Tesla as well as the alternating current
telling the masses that it was dangerous
and it would burn down houses and
entire cities which by the way Edison
knew was a flat-out lie
Edison's marketing campaign included
electrocuting dogs horses and even an
elephant in public in a disgusting
attempt to deceive and scare the masses
hoping that they would want DC instead
but his attempt of course failed and
here we are 130 years later and we are
utilizing the AC current throughout the
modern world and yet Thomas Edison
became famous the world over as we were
taught that he invented the light bulb
but we now know that that's not true at
all
Thomas Edison did not invent the light
bulb rather he purchased the patent from
Henry Woodward and Matthew Evans in 1880
and then he hired a team of 50 interns
to perfect the patent which he then
stamped his name on and made a fortune
incredible right and it was until just a
few years ago that they started teaching
otherwise in schools but do you want to
hear something that Thomas Edison did
event that almost nobody knows the
electric chair that's right Thomas
Edison made money off a device that he
created that would be used to kill
people and guess what else it uses the
DC current I said it before and I'll say
it again Thomas Edison was a liar he was
a killer of innocent animals for profit
and overall he was a person of
incredibly low character Edison was not
a brilliant inventor he was a brilliant
marketer and that's how he was
essentially able to fool most of the
world for more than a hundred years into
thinking that he had created the things
that he will actually haven't all that
aside let me get back to Elon Musk and
the video clip of the interview where he
was asked about Nikola Tesla and Thomas
Edison and it's about 51 seconds long
here's the clip and I'll have a few
really interesting points to make about
it right after here we go as far as role
models you know obviously some of the
obvious role models I think Edison was
certainly a role model what I probably
one the biggest role models yeah I read
books about him absolutely and ifs
interesting contrast like Edison versus
Tesla was interesting you know the car
companies called Tesla and the reasons
called Tesla is because we use an AC
induction motor which is an architecture
that Tesla developed and the guy
probably deserves a little more play
than he gets in current society but on
balance I'm a
big a fan of Edison and Tesla because
Edison brought his stuff to market and
made those inventions accessible to the
world whereas Tesla did didn't really do
that so that's so he'd certainly be a
big one so I have a few concerns but
then he first say that the more I learn
about Elon Musk the more I admire him we
need the world needs more people to
follow his footsteps
but at the same time the more I learn
about Nikola Tesla the more I admire him
as well keep in mind that this interview
was from 2008 but it's literally the
only example I could find where Elon
Musk discusses Nikola Tesla does anyone
else know of another example if so
please leave a comment in fact I saw
this interview on a YouTube video and
reading through the comments it was
blatantly clear that a lot of people
were very upset with Elon Musk's
responses and it also is worth
mentioning that Elon Musk has received a
lot of criticism in the past for not
having given Nikola credit or Nikola
Tesla enough credit for Tesla's an
enormous success with his car company so
basically in response to various past
criticism must-go went ahead and donated
1 million dollars to the Nikola Tesla
Museum in Belgrade and I think that's
absolutely fantastic huge props to Elan
musk for doing that but I and others
want to hear more from you on musk and
more recently about his opinions of
Nikola Tesla as well as Thomas Edison I
mean at first I was a bit taken back by
some of his responses but then they
thought about it take the first part
when he said that Edison was his role
model and he went on to say that he had
read books on him this does remind
ourselves that Elon Musk is brilliant
but at the same time he's not an
inventor he's not a rocket scientist he
is someone who has found a way to
improve humanity's future through the
use of technology while making
significant sums of money that can be
used for his desires to explore and
colonize space musk wants to go to Mars
and he has found a path to make that a
possibility so I understand where Elan
musk is coming from in regards to Edison
able to prop up his product and get it
out there and market it with
unbelievable success and by the way I
too had read a book on Thomas Edison in
fact I did a book report on him I don't
know probably like the sixth grade and
that book mentioned absolutely nothing
about a variety of things first of all
it's flat-out stated that Thomas Edison
had invented the lightbulb which wasn't
true and they didn't mention a single
thing about him discrediting Nikola
Tesla or the alternating current so is
it possible at Elon Musk isn't aware of
it either I mean make no mistake most of
the world has no idea about these
details and Elon Musk is spending his
adult life pursuing or pursuing other
interests and passions so I mean this
might be something that he had looked
into decades ago and hasn't revisited
since it is possible he doesn't know all
the details as most people don't and
also it's only a 51 second clip it's
just not enough to know his true
understanding of Edison or Tesla but I
am very curious to know what Ilan's
opinion is of Edison having electrocuted
animals as well as the lying and
deceiving the public involving Tesla and
discrediting him and just flat-out lying
to try and bolster his product I'd like
to know his thoughts on that and not to
mention electrocuting dogs and horses
and an elephants are you joking that's
only sick people would do something that
total sociopaths I mean what does that
tell you about somebody so in the next
part of the interview Elon acknowledges
that Tesla deserves more play than he
gets in current society and this goes
back to what I said the beginning of
this video about how most people are
completely unaware of who Nikola Tesla
is he's literally not taught in the
American public school system he's not
required learning by the Department of
Education and of course not included in
the common core subjects and this to go
to a private school or have a great
teacher who chooses to step outside the
curriculum he's just simply not required
testing and hence why so many people in
the United States have no idea who they
who he is in fact it's because of the
car company Tesla that people are
starting to figure him out because
they'll Google Tesla the car company to
figure out what the name means and
they're like oh my goodness there's
someone named Nikola Tesla but it has to
be mentioned that elsewhere in the world
this isn't the case like for example in
Europe particularly Eastern Europe I
know for sure they teach Nikola Tesla in
death so keep that in mind so the
question becomes for that I have for
Elon Musk is why do you think the Nikola
Tesla doesn't get that much attention in
current society I mean why is that why
is it that he's not being taught in
school so going back to the Elon Musk
interview when he mentions that Edison
had brought his product to the market
where Tesla didn't really do that now
that's true Tesla was not a successful
Marv
dinner whereas Edison was but Nikola
Tesla was taken advantage of and he died
poor at the age of 86 because of greedy
people such as Thomas Edison that took
advantage of them I mean we're talking
about the guy that invented the electric
motor I mean just stop and think about
how many things in your life that you
use an electric motor for and we never
really stop to think twice about it I
mean this is the same guy that also
invented the remote control
think about that and even the radio and
his inventions and his works had
contributed greatly to the inventions of
robotics lasers x-rays computers and
many other things and yet again most
people have no idea who he is
do a sidewalk pole in any city in
America and start asking people about
Nikola Tesla and the leaders say they
have no idea who he is or they'll be
like oh wait you mean the card company
now all this said this is not criticism
towards Elon Musk not at all I admire
you on musk and he is absolutely a role
model so is Nikola Tesla he's a role
model but in my opinion and many others
Thomas Edison is not a role model at all
but most people have a deep affection
for Elon Musk and I have watched many
videos on him and I can tell you that he
is he's definitely one of the good guys
but some people don't trust him because
of course SpaceX they have an
affiliation and had a huge contract with
NASA and well some people just don't
trust NASA so they don't trust you on
musk but it's worth mentioning that I
mean these people need to look into the
people that opposed Elon Musk and SpaceX
I mean even Neil Armstrong testified in
Congress to try and stop commercial
private companies from space exploration
I mean just think about that and look
into all the people that opposed Elon
Musk because of him he's doing what NASA
has failed to do for decades we've never
gone back to the moon
we haven't stepped foot on Mars and Elon
Musk has essentially become this beacon
of light for Humanity because he's doing
these things I highly recommend that you
research Elon Musk on your own
especially is upbringing if you look at
the fact him being bullied in South
Africa so severely that some kids threw
him down a flight of stairs and sent him
to the hospital
ultimately he overcame things that seem
to hold most people down with
insecurities and lack of confidence for
their entire lives and he has found a
way to press for it in fact this reminds
me of an outstanding quote which is the
wealthiest place on the planet is the
graveyard because in the grave
we will find inventions that we were
never exposed to ideas dreams that never
became a reality hopes and aspirations
that were never acted upon so when you
look at Elon Musk he's an unbelievably
humble person he denies that he's a
genius which so many people suggest that
he is and he has found a way to create
opportunities for himself which so many
people said he could not do he said he
was gonna fail at all these things well
there's Tesla the car company SpaceX and
everything else and here he is and this
is just the beginning guys but more than
anything I would like to know more from
Elon Musk on the subject of intuition
which is by the way something that
Nikola Tesla had described in detail and
so did Einstein let's ask Elon Musk
what's his opinion is on intuition and
gut instinct and how has that helped him
in his own life in his own career
success I mean make no mistake some of
the most successful people on earth have
discussed intuition in detail and that's
just something they don't teach about in
school anyways guys I'll leave it at
that but leave me a comment let me know
what your thoughts are on Elon Musk
Nikola Tesla Thomas Edison and hit the
like button and subscribe and I have
many other videos to come on a whole
wide variety of topics
I'm Jimmy this is bright insight take
care everybody